[Musik]
klimaschutz für europa die eu-kommission
erläutert ihren eine billion euro plan
für einen klimaneutralen kontinent die
grenzen der überwachung das
bundesverfassungsgericht prüft die
lauschangriffe des bnd im ausland
[Musik]
tierquälerei in bayern über monate
litten hunderte rinder auf einem hof im
allgäu jetzt stehen auch die behörden am
pranger
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den 19 uhr nachrichten am dienstag sport
gibt es auch dafür ist norbert lehmann
an meiner sei unschön wohl beim kauf
formieren im dezember hatte ursula von
der leyen einen green deal angekündigt
damit europa bis 2050 klimaneutral wird
also treibhausgase vermeidet um die
erderwärmung zu bremsen
dafür will die eu kommission in den
nächsten zehn jahren eine billion euro
investieren also 1000 milliarden
ihre chefin erklärte heute woher das
geld kommen und was damit passieren soll
aus straßburg stefan leifert noch ist
alles nur ein versprechen
ursula von der leyen hat es nun in
zahlen gegossen eine billion euro für
das klima soll her aber auch milliarden
für die die unter europas energiewende
leiden werden
mit diesem neuen mechanismus legen wir
unseren schwerpunkt auf die branchen und
regionen die vor den größten
herausforderungen stehen und die größten
anstrengungen vollbringen muss polens
städtchen la chambre through ist so ein
beispiel hierfür jeder vierte arbeiteten
bergbau die kohle hat den ort einst groß
gemacht dass der kohleausstieg ihn nun
wieder klein macht ist die große sorge
wir brauchen enorm viel geld und eine
systemlösung zur energiewende regierung
und eu müssen bei der umgestaltung der
berggaststätte helfen bis zu 100
milliarden euro will brüssel solchen
regionen in einem fonds zur verfügung
stellen insgesamt soll das
jahrhundertprojekt green deal über eine
billion euro mobilisieren die hälfte aus
dem eu haushalt ein drittel von privaten
investoren der rest aus den
mitgliedstaaten
das sind natürlich dann eigentlich
luftbuchungen und es ist nicht das was
es braucht um wirklich diese tradition
gerade für die ärmeren und abgehängten
region zu finanzieren
die eu kommission plant mit viel geld
von dem sie erst wenig zusammen hat von
der leyen stehen noch harte
verhandlungen bevor denn die rechnung
kann nur aufgehen wenn die
mitgliedstaaten ihre beiträge zum eu
haushalt erhöhen
dazu fehlt bisher jede bereitschaft
übrigens auch in berlin das große klima
versprechen steht also noch unter großen
finanzvorbehalt bis in die nacht hatten
russland und die türkei versucht im
bürgerkrieg in libyen zu vermitteln ohne
ergebnis jetzt soll eine konferenz am
sonntag in berlin helfen
in libyen tobt ein erbitterter
machtkampf auf der einen seite steht
general haffter nach dem sturz gaddafis
befehligte er einen teil der armee
kämpfte gegen islamisten
dann überwarf er sich mit
ministerpräsident sharaf der war nach
un-vermittlung 2015 zum chef der
international anerkannten regierung
ernannt worden
ihn unterstützt jetzt eine allianz in
der auch islamisten vertreten sind
andreas künast die umarmung die das
russische fernsehen gestern abend zeigt
ist die beste nachricht für libyen seit
jahren der türkische und der russische
außenminister
die vertreter der zwei vielleicht
mächtigsten kräfte die libyen zu
zerreißen drohen in libyen unterstützt
russland den mächtigen möchtegern
staatschef feldmarschall haffter mit
waffen und wohl auch söldnern die türkei
hat dem international anerkannten aber
machtlosen macht rabatz soldaten zu
hilfe geschickt in moskau hat jeder
außenminister seinen libyen dabei die
türkei überredet einen waffenstillstand
zu unterschreiben russland bearbeitet
haft aber der unterschreibt nicht wahr
schadhafter befehlshaber der libyschen
national armee hat das dokument positiv
bewertet aber um etwas mehr zeit gebeten
um zeit bis morgen früh aber heute früh
ist haftbar beck ohne unterschrift das
treffen in moskau gescheitert nächster
versuch berlin
für sonntag hat die bundesregierung
nicht nur die zwei libyschen rivalen
eingeladen sondern alle staaten die sie
unterstützen weil der krieg nur dann
aufhören werde wenn die einflussnahme
von außen beendet wird und alle die
einfluss nehmen sich darauf verständigen
zukünftig keine militärgüter mehr an die
unterschiedlichen parteien zu liefern
alle die von außen einfluss nehmen das
heißt ein dutzend staatschefs darunter
putin erdogan vielleicht trump berlin
steht vor einem aufregenden wochenende
nach dem abschluss der ukrainischen
passagiermaschine in iran sind dort
offenbar mehrere personen festgenommen
worden
details sind nicht bekannt präsident
rotary forderte lückenlose aufklärung
und ein sondergericht die maschine der
ukrainian airlines war kurz nach dem
start abgestürzt alle 176 insassen
starben
erst nach tagen hatte das militär
zugegeben das flugzeug irrtümlich
abgeschossen zu haben
wichtige verhandlung vor dem
bundesverfassungsgericht in karlsruhe
es geht darum ob der deutsche
auslandsgeheimdienst bnd seine
abhörpraxis im ausland so wie bisher
fortsetzen kann
vor dem bericht über die juristische
auseinandersetzungen zunächst einmal
fakten zum bnd christoph des tabelle hat
ziehen was auf dieser welt gefährdet
interessen und sicherheit der deutschen
wer alle gespräche von ausländern im
ausland mit bekommt kann das vielleicht
sagen genau das soll der bnd global
gefahren analysieren und bislang darf er
dafür ausländische handys laptops oder
ganze netze anzapfen dann gespräche
mithören und aufzeichnen
selbst ohne konkreten verdacht eine
riesenaufgabe 6500 menschen arbeiten für
den auslandsgeheimdienst entsprechend
groß die neue berliner zentrale der
reichstag wurde acht mal reinpassen
allerdings darf der bnd nur daten
sammeln und auswerten etwa wenn irgendwo
eine krise ausbricht reagieren handeln
ist dann sache der regierung doch der
sperre sind grenzen gesetzt
so sollen etwa technische filter dafür
sorgen dass der bnd keine deutschen
ausspioniert auch nicht im ausland denn
für deutsche staatsbürger gilt das
deutsche fernmeldegeheimnis überall auf
der welt
tja gilt das nur für deutsche oder auch
für ausländer
genau diese frage wird vor dem
bundesverfassungsgericht verhandelt
kläger sind die organisationen reporter
ohne grenzen und ausländische
journalisten
sie sehen das fernmeldegeheimnis und die
pressefreiheit verletzt
felix zimmermann die journalistin katja
schneider war arbeiteten also bei john
in ihrem heimatland deckt sie
korruptionsskandale auf höchster
regierungsebene auf spricht dabei mit
informanten
sie befürchtet dass ihre kommunikation
vom bnd überwacht wird dies kann ihre
journalistische arbeit gefährden wenn
wir journalisten unter überwachung
stehen können wir informanten kein
schutz gewährleisten und so werden sich
informanten nicht mehr an uns wenden
weil dies für sie nicht sicher ist
gemeint ist massenüberwachung durch den
bnd von ausländischen telefonaten und
emails hierzu zapfte geheimdienst
sogenannte internet knoten an
durch die suche nach der nadel im
heuhaufen können im besten fall
terroristen aufgespürt werden
doch auf fast der bnd auch viele
gespräche von völlig unbeteiligten
ausländern
dies verletze ihr recht auf geheime
kommunikation meinen kiddies mörder war
und andere ausländische journalisten
beim bundesverfassungsgericht haben sie
beschwerde gegen die bnd überwachung
eingereicht die entscheidende frage
heute vor gericht können sich personen
im ausland überhaupt auf deutsche
grundrechte berufen handelt sich bei dem
telekommunikationsgeheimnis um ein
menschenrecht und das kann nicht davon
abhängig gemacht werden welchen pass
jemand in der tasche hat der bnd
verweist hingegen auf seine rolle für
die sicherheit deutschlands wir sind der
auslandsnachrichtendienst also müssen
wir auch im ausland nachrichten
beschaffen können und dazu ist die
auslands auslands vermehrt auf klärung
die heute hier auf dem prüfstand steht
ein unverzichtbarer bestandteil
was hat vorrang deutsche
sicherheitsinteressen oder das
kommunikations geheimnis das wären die
richter am bundesverfassungsgericht bald
entscheiden
mehr geld für das schienennetz und
ungarn haben ein milliarden paket
beschlossen
verkehrsminister scheuer und bahn chef
lutz unterschrieben ein abkommen das in
den kommenden zehn jahren investitionen
in höhe von 86 milliarden euro vorsieht
so viel wie nie zuvor
davon trägt der bund 62 milliarden euro
und die bahn 24 milliarden bayern ein
neuer tierschutz kann dahl betroffen
diesmal einen großbetrieb mit 600
rindern
immer wieder war der bauernhof
kontrolliert worden immer wieder wurden
verstöße festgestellt
doch passiert ist bisher so gut wie
nichts in den letzten monaten gab es
mehrere ähnliche fälle im allgäu oder
sonne wald berichtet abgemagerte kühe
die zentimeter tief in ihren eigenen
fäkalien stehen und liegen manche haben
massive entzündungen und krankheiten an
den klauen
diese bilder aus einem milchvieh hof im
oberallgäuer dietmannsried stammen von
einem tierrechtsaktivisten wir haben
hier tiere gesehen die nur noch auf zwei
beinen sich hüpfend fortbewegen konnten
und auch einen sehr schlechten
ernährungszustand gezeigt haben der
großbetrieb mit 600 rindern wurde in den
letzten anderthalb jahren mehrfach
kontrolliert dabei wurden immer wieder
verstöße gegen das tierwohl festgestellt
es gab mahnungen und anordnungen doch
der landwirt konnte seinen betrieb trotz
der missstände ungehindert weiter führen
diese verstöße wurden entsprechend
weitergemeldet in chile dessen dass ein
landwirt sogenannte direktzahlungen
erhält aufgrund dessen dass diese
verstöße auch aktenkundig waren sind die
direktzahlungen gekürzt worden
bayerns umwelt- und verbraucherminister
thorsten glauber hat erst vor einem
halben jahr als reaktion auf einen
tierschutz skandal im allgäu ein neues
kontrollsystem eingeführt vor allem
großbetriebe werden seitdem intensiver
und unangekündigt kontrolliert dafür
sollen jetzt mehr stellen für veterinäre
geschaffen werden
kontrollen alleine reichen nicht aus
sagt die opposition in bayern für das
tierwohl müsste bei missständen
schneller und härter durchgegriffen
werden immer nur anordnungen zu erlassen
und dann zu sagen da der tierhalter hat
nicht darauf reagiert es reicht
überhaupt nicht aus da müssen aus meiner
sicht andere saiten aufgezogen werden
ansonsten ist es einfach schlicht
staatsversagen auf dem hof in
dietmannsried waren manche tiere in
einem so miserablen zustand dass sie
eingeschläfert werden mussten
das oberallgäuer landratsamt mit dem
bauern diese woche den bescheid über ein
tierhaltungsverbot zu stellen
nach tunesien seit 100 tagen ist der
neue präsident im amt anfangs war er
hoffnungsträger kreis seit aus frust
über die wirtschaftliche und politische
lage wählten vor drei monaten vor allem
die jungen tunesier den parteilosen
juraprofessor zum präsidenten
und jetzt wo steht das land von dem vor
neun jahren der arabische frühling
ausging
aus tunis berichtet christel happ
er hat die maske fallen lassen sagt aus
annaburg die 36 jährige spricht vom
präsidenten ein mann an dem sie geglaubt
für den sie sogar wahlkampf gemacht hat
jetzt ist sie ernüchtert
er hat kein klares programm mehr
er hat keine einzige mutige entscheidung
getroffen um tunesien voranzubringen
vor allem die wirtschaftssituation die
katastrophal ist
die site vom jura professor ohne
politische erfahrung zum präsidenten
sein erfolgsrezept im wahlkampf war das
direkte gespräch mit den menschen den
jungen tunesien versprach er bessere
zukunftschancen
ich werde eure forderungen umsetzen
mehr freiheit arbeit und würde es sind
wichtige forderungen ein versprechen das
er seinen wählern bislang schuldig
geblieben ist und so demonstrieren sie
heute wieder in der hauptstadt tunis das
vertrauen in die politik ist am
nullpunkt
die tunesier haben bewusst einen
außenseiter zum präsidenten gewählt und
die etablierten parteien abzustrafen
doch die erhofften neuen impulse für
wirtschaft und arbeitsmarkt sind
ausgeblieben
der präsident wird kraftlos trotz aller
enttäuschung bleibt so seien
optimistisch sie glaubt fest daran dass
tunesien die arbeitslosigkeit und armut
eines tages in den griff bekommen wird
alles hat ein ende auch windows 7 nach
zehn jahren stellt microsoft heute den
service für das computer betriebssystem
ein
nach expertenschätzungen haben mehr als
25 prozent der pc nutzer in deutschland
nach windows 7 auf ihren rechner
doch wer kein neueres programm
installiert wie zum beispiel windows 10
kann probleme mit seinem computer
bekommen und hacker haben leichtes spiel
an die daten zu gelangen ist enrique
diese meldung hat fast jeder windows 7
nutzer erhalten microsoft kündigt das
ende seiner unterstützung für das
betriebssystem seit einem halben jahr an
heute soll das letzte kostenfreie update
kommen
danach sind windows 7 rechner ein
potenzielles sicherheitsrisiko
im zweifelsfalle kann man auf alles
zugreifen was im rechner vorhanden ist
in so genannter schadcode kann eben über
sicherheitslücken eingespielt werden und
das kann eben so weit gehen dass
passwörter abgegriffen werden aus dem
online banking oder hochsensible daten
aus e mails und dergleichen dinge mehr
und der staat geräusch von windows 7
tatsächlich noch jeder vierte pc-nutzer
und dabei bietet microsoft ein
kostenloses update an bis heute der
offizielle zeitraum zum gratis umstieg
ist eigentlich vorbei aber das war wohl
mehr oder weniger auch ein marketing
trick von microsoft um schnell auf hohe
anteile zu kommen
der update assistent ist leicht zu
finden jede suchmaschine führt direkt
auf die entsprechende seite für firmen
können solche updates problematisch sein
gerade mittelständische unternehmen
verwenden oft maßgeschneiderte programme
die nicht ohne änderungen etwa auf
windows 10 laufen programme
umgeschrieben werden angepasst werden
aktualisiert werden
das ist bei solchen
individualentwicklungen eben ein
bisschen anders als besser für die von
der stange kommt
microsoft bietet firmenkunden noch bis
zu drei jahre technische unterstützung
für windows 7 an
das aber kostet für jeden rechner extra
für private nutzerdaten geht das nicht
da heißt es ab heute weitere updates
werden nicht installiert tja und nun zum
sport norbert unser handball-em da hat
sich das deutsche team ja gestern nicht
mit ruhm bekleckert hat dann kann man
wohl sagen hauptrunde zwar erreicht aber
kaum hoffnung aufs weiterkommen gelegt
beim glanzlosen zittersieg gegen
lettland bundestrainer christian prokop
hofft jetzt auf einen neustart in wien
und auf das steigerungspotenzial seines
teams während sich die meisten eine
mütze schlaf können auf dem
zweieinhalbstündigen flug von trondheim
nach wien hat der bundestrainer längst
mit der vorbereitung auf den nächsten
gegner weißrussland begonnen es gibt
viel aufzuarbeiten vor allem die
nachlässigkeiten in der schlussphase als
lettern das spiel fast noch gedreht
hätte julius kühn mit acht treffern
erfolgreichster torschütze und sehr
selbstkritisch in der analyse
es kommen jetzt einfach so akzeptieren
und nimmt es ist logisch dass wir uns
das alles anders vorgestellt haben jetzt
gibt es aber einen tapetenwechsel schild
weist an das nächste spiel an und ich
glaube dass es eine mannschaft die uns
extrem liegt weil sie auch sehr physisch
spielen ein sieg zwingend notwendig wenn
wir nicht zur endstation werden soll
skilangläufer dominik walldorf ist in
innsbruck wegen gewerbsmässigen schweren
sportbetrugs zu fünf monaten haft auf
bewährung verurteilt worden
er ist einer von 23 sportlern die in den
blutdoping skandal um den erfurter
mediziner marquez verwickelt sind
julia goerges und jan lennard struff
haben bei den tennisturnieren im
australischen adelaide ihre
auftaktspiele gewonnen und 735 kilometer
südöstlich in melbourne
ja da herrscht dicke luft zu beginn der
australian open wegen der buschfeuer es
geht beim besten willen nicht mehr
thalia jakupovic am boden sie bekommt
keine luft mehr
die slowenien musste ihr
qualifikationsspiel im flinders park
abbrechen
das erste tennis highlight des jahres
stöhnt unter dem feinstaub
er übertrifft deutsche spitzenwerte vom
stuttgarter neckartor um das zehnfache
wir haben uns entschieden das training
aufzuschieben und die
qualifikationsspiele um eine stunde nach
hinten zu verlegen
kleine korrekturen die jacobovici auch
nicht mehr helfen
obwohl sie nach sätzen führt wird das
spiel für sie als verloren gewertet die
organisatoren hoffen nun auf die
reinigungskraft des angekündigten regens
mögen wir ein segen hoffentlich kommt er
dort der zum wetter bei uns da gibt's
sturm und regen aber nur an der nordsee
sonst wird es meist mild und sonnig zu
den einzelheiten gleich kontaktiert das
war es von uns danke für ihr interesse
christian sieber ist freut sich schon
auf saisonal und auf sie um 21.45 und
wir sind dann morgen abend wieder für
sie da punkt 7 einen gemütlichen abend
noch chris
[Musik]
dann bliebe zuschauer die ruhigen tage
sind vorbei jetzt spürt man wieder in
den wind heute vor allen dingen
norddeutschland und in der mitte und es
wird noch wendiger und der wind pustet
uns jetzt nochmal mildes wetter nach
mitteleuropa aus dem südwesten das ganze
wird unterstützt von einem sturm und
orkantief das jetzt nach dänemark weiter
zieht also in den nächsten stunden wird
sie in norddeutschland und an der
nordsee noch weniger
da gibt es sturmböen aus dem südwesten
orkanartige böen vielleicht ganz im
norden auf sylt zum beispiel aber der
regen lässt nach vielleicht gibt es im
westen noch ein paar tropfen und im
süden wird es eh klar werden und das
heißt es wird wieder frostig kalt dort
in der vergangenen nacht 0 bis -5 grad
und sehr mild bleibt es im norden acht
bis zehn grad das sind nach temperaturen
wie im mai bei uns und tagsüber wird es
natürlich noch ein bisschen milder
da sind es dann etwa elf bis 14 zum teil
15 grad am oberrhein nur im südosten
bleibt es ein bisschen frischer mit vier
bis zehn grad aber es wird überall fast
überall ein freundlicher tag nicht nur
im süden auch im osten und
norddeutschland ist es freundlich mit
sonnenschein nur im nordwesten
da haben wir die dichten wolken
nachmittags wird es dort auch immer mehr
regnen und es ist weiterhin windig
stürmische böen an der nordsee weiterhin
sturmböen aus dem südwesten
ja und die aussichten es geht ähnlich
weiter bis zum freitag dann tauchen hier
im westen erste schauer auf und dann am
wochenende wird es schon wechselhafter
und auch langsam wieder kühler
ich wünschen noch einen schönen abend
und machen sie es gut